Hello, I'm Hank Green and this is Crash Course
Office Hours where I take some of the questions
and concerns that you had with the last episode
of Crash Course Biology and answer them or
address them.
We have an excellent question from MsLebbel:
"What is meant by polar?"
Now, when we were talking about this in the
last episode, we're talking about chemical
polarity which is when a molecule has a part
of the molecule that's positively charged
and part of it that's negatively charged.
Basically the molecule has become, itself,
a magnet.
This happens in a variety of molecules.
The reasons why it happens is very complicated,
but basically the electrons around the atoms
end up spending more time on one side of the
molecule than on the other side and so you
have a negative side and a positive side.
And that is what I meant by polarity.
MartinSabatonFan wants to know if there are
any other elements besides water and carbon
that life could be based on, and Martin, well,
we all would like to know that very much.
And my impulse is that, "No!
It could not possibly be possible.
Everything we know is based on water and carbon."
But, ya know, things that I can't imagine
happen all the time in the universe, and so
maybe it is possible, but I don't think we're
gonna know until they come knocking on our
door.
jamesahibbard asks, "Excuse me Mister Green,
but isn't steam, like a cloud, not a gas,
but a fine liquid?"
Uh, no, not really.
What we generally call steam in our everyday
life, the stuff that comes out of a kettle
or the the mist in our shower, isn't actually,
technically, steam.
That, as you say, is little tiny droplets
of water floating around in the air.
When scientists are talking about steam, what
they mean is gaseous water, literally water
that has been converted into a gas.
If you walked into a room filled with steam
instead of being like, "Ah, this is relaxing,"
you would, your face would melt off, you would
die very quickly.
It would be a very horrible horrible way to
die.
Steam, by definition, is hotter than boiling
water and it is a clear gas and it is one
hundred percent water.
Phylo45 and several other people pointed out
that, in fact, if ice were denser than water,
icebergs sinking to the bottom of the ocean
would not, in fact, raise the sea level.
And this is true and I apologize for misinforming
all of you.
Basically, an ice cube already displaces its
entire mass if it's floating in water.
But if the density was higher, higher than
water, and it was underwater it would actually
be smaller, taking up less space than an ice
cube floating on the surface of the ocean.
And its a little bit complicated.
But that person and the other ones who corrected
me on that, thank you.
And finally marc46o compliments me on my skill
as a teacher, but wonders if I'm doing this
by myself and I am certainly not.
Thank you to the people who are helping me
work on this.
We have Jenkins back there, behind the camera.
Come on out.
[from back] No.
[Hank] Nick is also editing these, thank you
Nick.
And then we have Blake and Jesslyn helping
me write them, and Amber and Pete are the
amazing people helping to do the graphics
on these.
So, thank you to all of them and I will see
you very soon in the next episode of Crash
Course.